a woman's uterus grossed over 500 times
its normal size
during pregnancy but not all changes are
visible in fact some of the biggest
changes happen in her brain when a
mother sees her newborn for the first
time it's love at first sight literally
that's because once she gives birth
whole regions of her brain's reward
network pick him they signal the release
of feel-good hormones like dopamine and
oxytocin into her blood which
immediately triggers a strong connection
of love and devotion to her newborn in
fact studies show that recent mothers
have similar levels of oxytocin as
romantic couples who are newly in love
and human mums aren't alone here
scientists discovered that rodents got a
bigger kick of dopamine from feeding
their pups than from receiving
injections of cocaine
what's more brain scans reveal that a
human mom has a similar experience when
she sees her infant smiling but it's a
different story when her baby is crying
those cries activate a network in the
mum's brain known as the emotion
regulation network it includes the
prefrontal and cingulate control systems
which help control her emotions and
that's important since it can be easy to
lose your temper
when you're running on very little sleep
and are distressed by the baby's cries
and while motherhood can be exhausting
new mums are actually more alert than
normal
thanks to their brains salience Network
scientists think giving birth activates
this network to help a mother detect
threats and protect her infant from harm
especially in dangerous situations when
that network can help ramp up adrenaline
but on a daily basis mum needs to
understand her newborns needs to
accomplish that she uses empathy which
comes from her brain's social network it
involves the insula and
Dola which researchers found became more
active when mums looked at photos of
their babies in distress
compared to neutral photos but it's not
just the mums brain that changes
research shows that a dad's brain
releases oxytocin when he interacts with
his baby - this is often accompanied by
a surge of another hormone prolactin
it's often called the milk hormone
because it triggers the production of
breast milk oh but men can produce it
too and researchers have found that dads
who frequently paid with their babies
had higher prolactin levels in their
blood than fathers who didn't they were
also more responsive to their baby's
cries so in the end having a child is a
big change not just feel a lifestyle for
your brain to